should probably open this would like the
sorting hat song but I don't remember it
and I'm too lazy to look it up yeah yeah
that could be the sorting hat that's
your sorting hat that's leather and
every time well yes okay so well we'll
address that in a second so everybody
thank you so much for joining us
My partner Liz is joining me for this
one and this this is something we
actually kind of dip for fun just to
pass the time like while walking
downtown and then we are at dinner and
still doing a we were still doing this
and we're good we just started taking
characters from other franchises that
aren't Harry Potter and sorting them
into Hogwarts houses and I decided this
is something I think I actually kind of
want to do it as an occasional series
but since we started doing to see other
I wanted to kick it off with you with a
franchise that you knew enough of the
characters to join me on cuz Doctor Who
yeah some of the ones I plan to do in
the future oh we should do Buffy's ho
Buffy's on the to-do list
don't worry for right now though we're
gonna talk about the characters from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe phase one
phase button only wait we'll probably
mention other ones do we might touch on
other ones but I'll probably get excited
about someone hopping yes possibly but
like I if this goes over well later on
we'll deal with some of the characters
that came in that came in later but for
right now so that this isn't an hour
long we're gonna do phase one so I guess
a little bit about us in terms of Harry
Potter which we're both fans of so I've
mentioned it more than a few times I'm a
Slytherin I am if I'd [ __ ] okay so I'm
kind of what I would say is like there
should be a WTF house cuz like where you
don't quite fit into all of them so
whenever I take the
test I tend to get different answers and
so for a while I was saying I was a
puffy slither claw but I'm probably just
a like hustle claw and because I'm you
know I've got that like cute like klutzy
personality of the Hufflepuff but I'm
also very analytical and a librarian so
that's Raven claw and I would probably
I've elected Raven claw as my house
that's what I would probably tell the
sorting hat to put me into but I have
gotten Slytherin on quizzes before and
I've gotten hufflepuff but I feel most
like akin to the Raven claw I mean I
think ultimately if the sorting had had
to make a call that's where they would
put you where this pose brings out the
big rule that we're going with this we
are not doing any sort of house mixing
we're not yeah we're not do I mean we
will acknowledge when something is a
tough call and if it's and we'll say
they should be in the WTF house yes but
we're not doing like slither clause or
Griffin puffs or whatever the the
different makes that we're not doing any
of that and so with that done this is
not going to be comprehensive of every
single character that appeared in phase
one probably not remember some of the
villains well a lot of them didn't make
a big impression
a lot of the villains I opted not even
to include because honestly I mean let's
be completely Frank most of the villains
are just especially in phase one are
just slytherins they mean they just
that's just what they are and most of
them aren't that entertaining to talk
about I do have a couple of villains on
here who I just yeah we'll get there
we'll get there okay okay okay so what
are your day let's get going so sorting
the MCU characters into Hogwarts houses
so let's start off with oh gosh okay
yeah that's a hard one I wasn't actually
gonna start with him even though we
stopped at the list but let's start with
characters from the first MCU movie
which is Iron Man we won't start with
Tony okay cuz they need to think I knew
Jim what about what do you think for
pepper potts oh I'm gonna say Gryffindor
I guess but she's got some Hufflepuff
leanings she is I think you like my
inclination was Hufflepuff but I think
you might be right because only somebody
as strong-willed as a Gryffindor could
ever get Tony you don't even slightly
listen to her cause that's the thing she
doesn't just put up with him
she is actually able to like point him
at him yeah point at least point him in
a direction and get him to do you know
listened to where he should be headed so
I I feel like if she was more huffily
she'd be a little bit more camp enabling
a neighbor him much and yeah she doesn't
definitely have her own well she's a
Gryffindor I really like though and like
she has the good Gryffindor qualities of
like you know really just being
supportive and loyal and but also having
you know I deals and motivations and
working towards them hmm so yeah I think
I'm comfortable with that one
so that's pepper what about what about
roadie
what about Warmachine I don't remember
him very well oh yeah
what do you think of him and then I'll
try to I'm thinking on it Rob I don't
know because it certainly if I'm if I'm
gonna compare him to pepper he is a lot
more enabling and he like he talks a
decent game about pushing back on Tony
he doesn't actually stand up to him very
much I haven't actually seen especially
in the first movie cuz there were two
different actors what was Tarrant it was
Terrence Howard and now it's um Oh God
Don Cheadle thank you why
so I don't I don't remember I guess I
think I've owned the last time I saw the
first movie was when it came out which
was what 2008 yeah I think yeah in years
ago so that's why I'm not remembering
him very well I and I'm thinking
specifically because I'm guessing and I
actually do remember that like Terrence
Howard and Don Cheadle had slightly
different takes on the character so I'm
trying to go with first movie version
yeah and I just I guess I get it like
gryffindor reaction to him but you could
be are you thinking more Hufflepuff I I
figure he's one of the two yeah
I'm Joe yes if I were to make a call and
if I were to come down somewhere I
I feel I like at the end of the day he's
he is kind of just an orders follower so
uh-huh I feel I feel like he's a little
bit more huh 'full we're not saying that
all hufflepuffs or our rule father no I
mean really if you look at like Newt
he's not really no no he's absolutely
not I mean that's the thing you need to
realize what we're doing here is that we
are going to be going with what the
prevalent stereotype of a Hufflepuff
Gryffindor Ravenclaw Slytherin are you
look at Luna and you're like yeah look a
raven definitely if there was ever a
case for a WTF how Luna would be yeah
like she and Neville would be like head
boy and head girl WTF it's so like if we
say anything that makes people go not
all huff foals are like that or not all
grips with those like we we acknowledge
that not trying to offend anybody but
like we we are just trying to have fun
with it go with us I knew you can
certainly are free to disagree in the
comments oh there was going to be a war
in the comment section over this video I
have no doubt I had you know I had one
more from the first film but I think
I'll skip it since you don't remember
the film very well so we gotta talk
about Tony and Tony
I feel like Tony has a bit of everything
except hufflepuff yeah um I say I
I'm gonna go with Ravenclaw cuz he's
like super smart and like a lot of it
revolves around that and his technology
he's definitely got some slither and I
would go either of those two but I'm I'm
gonna I'm gonna have to take him for my
house he does have a bit of Slytherin in
him I think I'm gonna agree with you
though and I think a lot of that has to
do with the fact that ultimately we're
what kind of makes a big difference for
him in terms of whether or not I would
put him in Slytherin is he can be very
self-centered and self-serving
but part of that is willful ignorance
once it is put in his face the impact of
the stuff that he does he doesn't keep
doing it yes and Raven Coston can be
very willfully ignorant yeah I think
Ravenclaw's sometimes potentially choose
to not consider the impact of their
actions because most no impact if they
think they don't want to have to deal
with that they're busy with other stuff
and I think that does kind of fit Tony a
bit yeah
so I think we'll talk Tony up to
ravenclaw the second Avengers movie he
definitely feels very Raven collage -
hmm yeah the side he came down on Civil
War I could see Raven claw again against
okay now we've got I've only get I'm
only gonna pull one character from The
Incredible Hulk movie and it is I
haven't seen that well you don't have to
because the Hulk also showed up in the
Avengers which is phase one okay so now
here's the big question do we do Bruce
Banner and the Hulk as one or do we say
or do we separate them and do them as
different people because I think I don't
want to do them both it's like separate
them okay cuz I think Bruce Banner is
very Ravenclaw I mean like yeah science
bros with tony was an immediate thing i
it's rose I love them both they're like
two of my favorite vendors - okay so I
mean are they pretty much are my two
favorite Avengers so are we comfortable
with that with putting Bruce as a
ravenclaw
the rack up the ravenclaw Avengers the
question now becomes what do we do with
Hulk he's not cutting enough or slither
and the man does he just writes up oh he
really does like maybe he is a drunk
hufflepuff there we go John I'm not sure
that I agree with that but I love it so
much that I don't have the hard to argue
with it
part of me wants to say Gryffindor but I
just love the idea of drunk up up up too
much I'm just gonna get drunk I'm
reporting that said speaking of
Gryffindor's let's start looking at some
respect in America I know we'll get some
of the cast of Thor Oh Thor
yeah and we can start with Thor himself
yeah could you really ever make the
argument that he's anything else no no
no no you really can't
yeah he's pretty clear-cut yeah now
let's let's talk another very clear-cut
and that's why the class so wonderfully
it's the Gryffindor Slytherin clash yeah
there I think
Loki might very well be the
quintessential
well I would say in the Marvel Universe
he might have an attic universe he might
have competition from one other
character and we'll get to him but he's
definitely right up there like if you
were to if somebody knew the Marvel
Cinematic Universe sexy Slytherin - he's
got that like he wears green yeah yeah
he looks good in green got stapes hair I
mean come on I didn't feel like if
somebody knew the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but didn't know Harry Potter
and they're like what are slytherins
like you would just go Loki and they
kind of leave it at that
yeah a little bit tougher though Odin
oh not Hufflepuff no no definitely not
my inclination is Gryffindor but like
like a cooled Gryffindor like he's he's
old enough that the fire is not what it
was but I think that's probably still
the best fit yeah I mean he could work
for any of the other three houses yeah
I'll give it that to you cuz he's more
like the word and low-key so Gryffindor
in that regard would make sense but he's
got some I don't know I think I'm
influenced by comic book Odin - and he's
a little Slytherin asking more so in the
comics that's that's true he is
restricting it to cinematic universe I
think the cinematic okay what do we
think about Jane Foster
do you remember Jane Foster
Jane Foster Oh Natalie Portman you so
did not want to be in those no I mean
that at this point like you can really
tell most the people in these movies
really love doing them but in the in the
earlier ones there were handful of
people like you you really were you were
grant taking this job she's one
Christopher Christopher Eccleston is
another one there was he he was the
villain in the second Thor oh gosh he
did not like that job and I don't regret
sleeping through it yeah yeah I mean the
easy call would be to say ravenclaw
because she's sciency yeah is that too
simple [ __ ] orphaned or - yeah
they're boring Gryffindor couple I'm
sorry
shots fired
Wow okay Gryffindor's add the puppies
for their tall
not really my house I mean yeah I'd say
yeah it's throw in Gryffindor I don't
really I was you just don't want her in
your house I mean we'll take her but
well you will make give her some will
put it will make us science wing for
well here's the thing here's the here's
the supporting character and I'm only
gonna mention him because he does show
up again that I think we would have put
in Raven claw Erik Selvig who's the
older sciency guy huh he gets drunk with
Thor oh he's super fun Raven claw yeah
that means stellan skarsgård yeah he's
you're the [ __ ] up you're going you're
crazy
yeah you're crazy Raven claw uncle yeah
yeah okay
he's someone oh I would rewatch the
first Thor for that him and kat dennings
kat dennings is fun she can be gosh what
is she her I don't even remember her
character's name but I really liked her
so we're gonna go with we're gonna put
her into so kat dennings character's
name is i honestly cannot remember
either
um she she might be a Slytherin yeah I
think she's a Slytherin yeah yeah that
that feels right yes me not that fly not
the strongest Slytherin that I can think
of but I think if you if the Hat was
gonna make a call that's where she land
I said we'd have fun in Slytherin yeah
she would not have fun in Gryffindor
okay so let's talk about Captain America
so Gryffindor he is but here's the thing
normally you tend to roll your eyes at
the Griffin nose I feel like much like
he is the idealized human being like
Steve Rogers Captain America is what you
get when all of Endor goes right when
all of the best possible elements up
being a Gryffindor are boosted to their
max and all of the weaknesses are dialed
down to just a background noise you get
Steve Rogers hey I put pepper in
Gryffindor and I love I love pepper
I and it's funny because I did not
really like Gwyneth Paltrow and most
things until I saw her and the first
Ironman and I was like I like her in
this world I really like pepper of what
is going on so
Gryffindor's know that me putting pepper
in your house is like a huge vote for
you but yeah I vote of confidence Steve
Rogers absolutely yes is a Gryffindor I
just don't love Steve Rogers and Captain
America as much as everyone else on the
planet like I like him okay but it's
it's okay because we use a little too
square for me yeah I know I am that and
everyone will yell at me in the comments
and that's fine you just met well I
think and also now that I think about it
I think it reinforces Tony's placement
in ravenclaw pretty well because it's
that clash of their approaches that
cause the difference because Steve is
very know this is what's right this is
what's wrong where Steve is whereas Tony
is a bit more well no because if we look
at it and break it down and put it apart
we canary we can come at it from another
way that will work better and Steve's
just going I don't care if that works
better it's wrong he could analyze for
hours yes you're good he is yours in of
a ravenclaw yep good new ravenclaw trait
okay so that's Steve Rogers uh Peggy
Carter I love her um Peggy Carter
hmm
it's not an easy call I mean again
natural inclination a lot of a mix of
thing she is I don't think she's got a
ton of Hufflepuff Fenner yeah I mean
we're not gonna find a lot of
hufflepuffs until we get to you okay can
we just say the quintessential
Hufflepuff that isn't in this face Peter
Parker he's making right Hufflepuff Pete
he's so adorable he's like he's just the
cutest couple ever I think Peter is very
much a ho and we mate you know what I
like
I'd like smuggle myself into their dorm
to hang out with Peter Parker like I'm
not I'm not even gonna fault you for
bringing him up because I feel like with
with the phase one characters huh falar
gonna be underrepresented and the ones
that we've got so far are like yeah yes
so yeah that's a fair play to have
mentioned him but but coming back to to
Peggy like I don't think there's any
helpful in there she can be a bit sly
but I mean that's kind of the gig she's
a little bit of an espionage character
uh-huh but she's also very much got the
the firm moral grounding for her I mean
that's why inclination having cheated
but they are not a boring movement or a
couple because she is fun and I like her
you know she's a pepper what she's a
Gryffindor working in a Slytherin job
yeah pretty much I need too much more of
that series too agent Carter I liked
like the I didn't I didn't love it the
way a lot of people I know love it but
it's pretty solid so this one's tough
because I want to try and restrict the
answer this time to how he was at this
point in the franchise and that's Bucky
oh good I feel like so the first captain
yes just first Avengers because I feel
like we start talking Winter Soldier the
game changes oh yeah um can we talk
about
we're what are the phase one movies
because I want to make it so that phase
one films were Iron Man Iron Man - okay
Iron Man - okay so we're gonna get to
Black Widow yes Incredible Hulk okay
Thor Captain America Avengers okay
gotcha so coming back to Bucky original
flavor Bucky um I don't remember
original flavor about Gilligan I also
felt sorry for Captain America I think
he might be a huffily yeah he stops
being a huff I will give like they if
you are Bucky you get to change houses
after that dress like he didn't
ain't no helpful anymore well he wasn't
for a stretch but then again if you
think about him in say infinity war
where he's like been working to
basically reclaim his own identity okay
I guess he's gone back to his phone and
in fun he had a fun rip-roarin time at
the slither in those moments
oh yeah yeah oh he was a good Slytherin
so well he and Loki oh man so put Bucky
and Hubble so they needed to team if I
had my way I would have liked a Loki
Bucky as Winter Soldier team up and like
they would never wash their hair and
cause all sorts of evil and like really
like I got like Tony and Steve oh I feel
like that is the gauge of evilness for
buck for Bucky how greasy is his hair
what did he get some shampoo in there
he's fine okay so now let's start well
you didn't wash it for like 50 years
okay what it was a while there let's
start talking some of the shield folks
okay so we can start with Natasha black
right there yeah
Oh Lutheran Slytherin Slytherin yeah she
she is she is very very Slytherin and
she she can be very self-serving she
does have a little bit more of a
personal moral compass and again I'm not
saying slytherins are a moral but I'm
saying slytherins are slytherins are
more often driven by what gets the best
result as opposed to what is the
unprincipled best thing to do so she
does dip into that a little bit but she
absolutely goes about it in the most
slither slither in a way possible even
when she yes even when she decides she's
going to do the quote-unquote right
thing she's gonna do it really slither
any yep yes that said I do think there
is someone who is more Slytherin than
her and I think gives Loki a little bit
of a run for his money and that's Nick
Fury Oh Nick Fury is soon worse leather
oh yeah yeah and and like if if Loki is
the I'm out for me for myself version of
Slytherin Nick Fury is the I'm out to
get the best final results
Slytherin so he's not out for himself
but he doesn't really care about the
morals of any of this his eye is only on
what's the end result should not be
Slytherin wondering yeah I mean I love
him so like he's my kind of Slytherin
but I mean there probably something
maybe not in the Star Wars movies but no
but then again yeah like the prequels
characters are such wooden blocks there
honestly
are some people where I just like with
Jane Foster I just don't care um you
didn't get the Hogwarts letter okay
thank you're too boring you're basic
that's that's a devastating insult
you're devastated right now
so okay so yeah yeah don't get me wrong
I love Natalie Portman and other roles
like especially the professional I still
need to see Black Swan
but and V for Vendetta oh my gosh she's
amazing and she is phoning it in for the
two Thor movies she was in oh I've got
I've got another actually I think this
is probably the strongest huffily
actually in this lineup
Phil Coulson okay I do remember who he
is I think wait who is he he is the
SHIELD agent who sort of recurs for a
little bit and then he dies and the
Avengers yes what spoiler warning for an
eight-year-old movie uh-huh yeah I was
gonna say I think I know who he is I
never got into the shields show no yeah
sorry six-year-old movie well I mean if
you're gonna take the show into account
he he is a he is a huffily goes dark
over time but like I feel like his
natural state is very much I'm here to
support everybody and I mean just watch
The Avengers just watching him fanboy
over Captain America yeah I would be
like the only person that didn't I'd be
like hey Steve I'm gonna go talk with
Tony now and then fangirl you over Bruce
Banner oh you you and Tony could go
snark in the corner about what ask where
Steve is oh yeah oh my gosh we would
have fun yeah okay so rounding out the
shield folks from the Avengers
Hawkeye hmm he's actually a tougher call
I think be especially like here's what I
would say I would say go ahead and take
into account the later films cuz he
hasn't really changed as a character I
like him but I never really get a full
sense of his character like I it's not
that I think maybe he's a little
underdeveloped I just AM like I don't
think he's underdeveloped but I think I
and this is where actually one of the
things I like about him especially as we
found out in the second Avengers movie
he plays things incredibly close to the
best
and we sort of realized that when we see
him like on a farm but the fan with a
wife and two kids and like you never
would have called that about this guy
cuz he just he just plays everything so
close to the best mmm which is kind of a
Slytherin trait but I'm not sure he
really is though like on the whole let
me think so I I don't I don't think he's
a Gryffindor because it's like he needs
to be too too flexible to be working SP
enough okay maybe he's helpful I guess
like he could be why I could buy that
from him he's not really think it's not
fun enough to be further no no yeah me
he's an unambitious than that really
that's also true he's actually you get
the sense especially when you see the
family on his on his farm that he is
actually quite content with the simpler
things when he has the chance to have
them so I had read the skull down here
but i think well actually you know what
i still want to talk about him because i
think red skull if I were to peg him is
a oh no gone bad
no I was gonna say ravenclaw gone bad
because he's very into you not really
feather any no he's not like a darker
version of one of the other houses III I
want to say Raven close with him and
well I don't think the film quite did as
hard as I want he he does have some
scary principles but largely he wants to
he's into the sign he's into the
development he's into the what weapons
can I make what what can I learn from
this he has Cosmic Cube and the cut
because he's he's a little bit of a to
make a real work comparison he's a
little bit of a doctor Mengele type and
like if you want a real world absolute
worst version of a ravenclaw that
would probably do we're scary when we're
evil yeah really scary cuz we're really
smart and we're real powerful there are
definitely evil Ravenclaw's and other
franchises yes
like divergent that wolf for the first
two books before I really went off the
rails that series the the main villain
is an evil ravenclaw so that whole house
kinda or that whole I thought my route
goes evil I feel like as much reading
class speak in general I feel like as
much as a lot of people not altogether
unfairly tend to assume that slytherins
are private or that villains are
probably slytherins I think it depends
on the type of villain if you're dealing
with a self-serving villain yes odds are
they're probably a Slytherin if you're
dealing with a they are doing horrible
things because they don't care about the
human toll you're probably dealing with
a ravenclaw yeah and then every now and
then you get the the true believer
villain who's doing horrible things
knows it's a horrible thing but believes
in the cost so strongly I feel like
that's your Gryffindor villain and those
are pretty uncommon but they are who
just smash I think a Hufflepuff god evil
would be pretty terrifying though
because they would they would be so
sweet and like they could definitely
fool you I don't know that I feel like
there would have to be some kind of
catalyst that turns them though yeah cuz
they seemed a little like least likely
to go go dark but I wish when they go
dark old man I wish I could remember Oh
who the heck they said there was some
commenter when I did my video about you
know being Slytherin in general somebody
made a comment about oh this character
is like a Hufflepuff combat and I it was
a really good example I wish I could
remember what the heck it was now
whoever you were a comment
yes please cannot remember and I did not
read that comment okay I think we'll
wrap it up there I'm gonna do a quick
tally I think of how many we've got okay
wait what about when did um now I can't
think of his name because I got a phase
one and when you said hot guy I was
actually thinking of this character cuz
of the wings Oh Falcon yeah when the
Falcon Falcon does not show up until
Phase two
he's a Winter Soldier winters is where
he shows up okay nevermind well we'll
get to them in the next one
yay okay so another one - well do we get
do we get in - yes yes that'll be it
that'll be an interesting conversation
oh my gosh there's so much fun I love
that motley crew okay I'll hold off
though okay so here's what we've got we
have the fewest slytherins largely
because we kind of skipped a lot of the
villains so like if I had put them down
characters like say Justin Hammer or
Obadiah Stane they they probably would
have been slytherins but they're also
not very interesting as characters and I
also expect you don't remember that very
interesting so there we've so we've got
four slytherins
four Ravenclaw's to my surprise five
huts oh wow yeah and - not my surprise
six Gryffindor's yeah that's pretty
heavy a friend art but again you know I
wait as we get to the guardians of the
galaxy and throw everything amok with
that like that that's gonna be some
slytherins with that one that's gonna be
an interesting one to sort out and and
like I said this this was by no means
comprehensive there were plenty of
characters that we skipped didn't even
forget like willfully skipped plus ones
we just flat-out would have forgotten so
I would love to hear other people's
thoughts on this about the one
that well disagree with yes the ones
that we sorted your thoughts on that the
ones we skipped because there's plenty
of them so by all means have at it
and this was fun yeah thanks we'll
probably do this again but for right now
well we'll leave it at that folks so
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff you
can do because there's buttons and
there's links including one to the
patreon which you want check it out I'd
appreciate it if you don't
don't sweat it because at the end of the
day you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned you're learning my
sign-off I love it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]